our two board view on the right side Min
and Arjun era geisey I think that match
might be close and on the left side we
have Magnus and Eric and for the Magnus
fans out there they don't want the match
to be close they want to see Magnus
dominant as he has been doing
yeah I mean uh it's Magnus with white
pieces obviously the pace is very very
quick from both players maybe some of
the quickest we've seen Robert I mean
they they're both 45 seconds and they're
right deep into the middle game I'd say
that Magnus has a slight advantage in
the position you see because he's got
this lovely Central Square that his
Queen is sitting on and um this Square
could be deadly later on but Eric
getting counter play now
Eric's doing this perfectly but that
Bishop Anna f8 Simon we saw in an
earlier match just a bad piece compared
to the Knight on D2 which will reroute
to the light Square so
I like Max's position Eric seemed a
little upset at himself there and by the
way the chat they've made predictions
they said 43 of them said that Eric was
for under three points 44 said three to
five twelve percent think so score five
or more points five is a lot to ask for
against Magnus
I'd I'd be happy getting that half point
I would uh hold on to that for the rest
of my life in bullet chess
um I mean we can see now Magnus moving
his work all the way down to the end
getting a dangerous background there but
more pieces getting exchanged
the problem with Black's position here
uh I would say Robert is the bishop look
at Black's Bishop Eric's Bishop is like
a big Pawn it's trapped in by the two
Central pawns and White's night
beautiful in the middle of the board and
just positionally speaking even though
Magnus is only one Pawn up well there he
goes two pawns up
that Bishop just can't do anything
so the first game seems to be going
magnus's way the bishop was bad the
clock management was a problem that C7
Pawn that's nearly queening is an issue
Magnus too fast too strong gets game one
and we see on the right hand side of a
screen it looks like Min he's about to
take game one opposite colored Bishops
do not necessarily mean to draw
especially if you split past pawns as
you just did now he's up a queen and
he's enough time origin resigns Min
takes game one
yeah that's um okay well they're both
off and I suppose the the Magnus game
going the way we had fought and now he's
playing the perk opening and lots of
pieces getting exchanged there and that
is generally good news for black uh to
equalize the position Eric really needs
to get going at the start of this match
and uh actually now he's generated some
pressure here I wouldn't have swapped
Queens against Madness try to keep the
Queens on against this guy he's so good
for the Queen's off the board
um and how how do you think they're
gonna commiserate or celebrate
afterwards uh Robert you know as they're
in the same room do you think they might
have a shandy afterwards I think
celebrate is definitely what they'll be
doing no matter well if Magnus loses
they don't think they'll be celebrating
but I don't think Magnus is going to
lose so I think they will be celebrating
and I I don't think we want to talk
about how they're going to be
celebrating but they might live stream
it so there is that oh wow that'd be
awesome to see as well uh I think it's
probably better for their vibrations
that Magnus wins because he's supposed
to win and if Eric does pull off a big
upset
I don't know is the party gonna be as
good I'm not sure so um yeah you know
we've got to think about these social
things before you party
and black seems to be doing quite well
here in in the game again I'm looking at
the game between Eric and Magnus Robert
I mean nice last move there
look at that King I mean the king is on
D4 with a pass Pawn in front of it and
this is a good lesson use your King as a
weapon in the end game it doesn't need
to be defended it's not going to get
checkmated so I like the way that Magnus
is handling this he's forcing the white
king back and if oh Knight to C4 coming
that is going to be a win for Magnus
very good move there the the backwards
night moves are said to be some of the
hardest moves to spot and uh look at
that Big D Pawn okay he's lost the pawn
now but after an exchange on D2
Magnus goes into a winning King and pawn
ending two extra pawns and it's two nil
to Magnus already Eric giving a little
smile there they can obviously hear each
other I'd love to know what they're
saying anyone who's a lip reader in our
audience can you please tell us what do
we think they're saying to each other
Robert what do you reckon Eric said
Magnus there was it something we can
repeat on air or maybe
um I think it probably had the word
buddy in it because that is a common
Canadian word especially from Eric but
yeah I'm guessing they're just having a
little fun chatting with one another uh
but look at this game I think this is
Eric's I see the eval bar but I'm
looking at the clock like Eric is well
ahead in the clock but his Knight is
trapped oh my gosh what recognition by
Magnus oh and it's still trout
unbelievable
I mean uh how do you how do you even be
how can you beat Magnus I mean it's just
so so hard
and uh also we should just talk about
the score in the other match as well I
mean uh at the moment
going really against Arjun but Arjun is
attacking in the current position he's
got pressure against light skin his
Queen coming in this would be a great
chance to get at least a point on the
board for Arjun yes so we will go back
to a two board View and we see that
Arjun gone for the attack I mean those
weak dark squares in front of the black
king the opening of the H file both
could be a problem but you know that man
is racing with the F7 Pawn on G6 he
wants to open the seventh rank so that
his King feels defended and great play
by Min he is already up three nil and we
just saw a Magnus do his job and that
game over there he's up three nil as
well but look at this
the force mate for men
yeah he's turned it around I mean it
looked a bit uh suspicious his position
but you know he brilliant chest to come
straight back in and get another point
on the board and he's looking very
strongly at the moment
um Magnus and Eric I mean they're
whitewashers so far I mean complete
white washers come on Eric and Arjun
let's see some points on the board
I think the lower seeds the players who
are the underdog have struggled mightily
to score points we've seen that in all
matches the closest was actually David
paravian 11 half five now we did get a
score correction uh that the game went
down his way not David so it was still a
six point margin but Simon looking at
these matches I think we might be
talking about eight point margins
because the high rated bullet players
are running away with it
yeah it looks that way but you do say
that I think this is Eric's best chance
so far if you look at Eric's position
he's got to be a little bit careful
about magnus's pawns but I do like his
Bishop better than the Knight I I again
I say that and he has to give it up for
the night
maybe he could get a draw out this this
should be there should be a draw right
Simon look at the clock Eric has no
chance of making a draw here he's down
14 seconds
maybe Magnus will fall sorry for him
that that is one way to make a draw but
I don't think Magnus feels sorry for
anyone no no you can't I mean it's
bullet chess you it's a competition
you've got to use all your assets
including the clock and now we actually
get a position where Magnus is a pawn up
as well so it could be four nil in that
match
and what I would give Erica drawer no
chance no chance that Magnus was gonna
do that he wins again but on the other
board it looks like Arjun Eric icy has
given his opponent midlay a queen but
black is the one delivering Checkmate
that was an incredible sequence white
has a queen but no hope because the King
on F1 is being obliterated by the Rooks
of the night
that's beautiful absolutely beautiful
finish there and that shows the talent
of Arjun he and fire brilliant tactics
into the game he's gonna need to do more
than that and at least he stopped the
rot and that is important stop the rot
yes
sorry go ahead Simon I was just
wondering how you can stop the Magnus
rot though I mean is that possible
it looks like this position is great for
Eric I mean the eval bar saying black is
much better but it looks not very clear
to me is Eric just up a pawn and that's
that
yeah I think so I mean he seems to have
good Rooks in the center he's got that
extra Pawn uh the Black Knight seems
good the black Bishop site does again
seem like a good chance for Eric to at
least get half a point but why not a
whole point here is that a second Pawn
you can grab now
he has he's grabbed the second Pawn
and the key to beating Magnus I wouldn't
know from experience or from what I've
seen is not taking your foot off the
proverbial gas pedal just keep going
keep playing don't spend too much time
because look at this Simon all of a
sudden I'm looking to clog oh gosh Eric
is down now six seconds and there's a
pin on the last rank that looks deeply
unpleasant Rook takes a fate with Bishop
B4 was in the air as well
it's so tricky isn't it to play against
Magnus because he just spots every
possibility and now Magnus has won a
piece as well come on Eric we just want
you to get a point I'll take half a
point Eric just get half a point on the
board but I don't think it's gonna be
this game no Knight takes F5 just
removing the guard take G4 g7s hanging
H4 as well so it's four sequence we'll
look at Magnus he's giving up his pieces
as long as he keeps his Rook on the
board he will win this game on time
sadistic
maybe you have to be sadistic to be the
best player of all time
oh yeah it's got the drawer
and Eric Hansen scores his first half
point and we just saw someone walk
towards Eric and bring him some juice
and then I thought I saw that same
person in the mirror behind Magnus so
they really might be like in the same
room or across the hall from each other
I think they can hear each other I I you
know I've never seen this before where
the two players play you know playing
can actually hear each other they can
hear the pain of the opposition But Eric
has got the draw and I think you could
see that Magnus was quite annoyed with
that because I think he wanted to get
the The Sweep you know he wanted to win
every single game and that's not
possible anymore so I think Eric can
hold his head high now
yeah might still be a very lopsided
match when it ends and right now
actually Magnus is up in exchange but
his King is in some danger Magnus the
black pieces here but I don't see The
Knockout and if that's the case then the
material should speak volumes
yeah I like what Eric's doing though oh
he can take the Knight and take on G6
can he with a drawer at least so yeah I
mean just take the Knight oh he hasn't
gone for it wow
and there was a chance there for Eric to
get another draw by just going straight
for the black king but instead he allows
black strong Knight to remain on the
board and the black king looks very
exposed but I don't think White's got an
enough pieces attacking you nope then
after Rook FDA we saw the look in Eric's
face that was the look of frustration of
playing Magnus Carlsen Magnus takes
another point so he is sailing through
in this Opening match it's great play
from Magnus I mean yes there might have
been a draw but I think that's the
operative word Simon I didn't see the
exact Perpetual if black didn't take
that Bishop on G6 and so Eric probably
looked at like I should have it but I
don't see the finish line and that's why
he tried to play a move and it didn't
work out
yeah it was quite a natural move he
played but again Magnus had it well
covered as always and now we see Magnus
attacking on the king side and I like
the way he's mixing up different styles
people maybe some people assume a bit
wrongly that Magnus is just the kind of
positional player loves the ending
because that's kind of what he's famous
for but I tell you what when Magnus
attacks he's also one of the best
players in the world at attacking
oh you say attack he says how badly do
you want this attack Rook H3 is about to
deliver mate on h8 and oh Queen h8 takes
G7 is the big threat
oh and uh oh look at that a lovely
tactic spotted by Magnus just making
sure the black king is trapped and this
move was the important thing at the end
that was a difficult combination to see
there Robert and he spots it straight
away
difficult for us maybe but not for the
Superhuman Magnus Carlson and he's done
a piece right now so he's trying to
figure out how do I actually end this
game and this doesn't appear to be the
right way but you've said this all day
Simon the evaluation bar get go away who
cares this is gonna should be a win for
white
I think so I mean again the evaluation
bar as you say is
oh he's blundered a mating one the world
champion
not a world champion but the strongest
player in the world Falls from eight in
one
oh my gosh we both said the wrong thing
there I was like oh Magnus yo he's got
this one and you know he just allowed a
Checkmate on G2 he laughs it off but
Simon we've covered enough of magnets we
know him he's probably pretty upset
about that
he's crying a little bit inside I think
there uh but maybe someone's gonna hand
him a drink now maybe a special drink I
don't know whatever whatever drink Eric
got there he did the job give that man
more of those drinks is all I'm thinking
yeah normally I'm not thinking that but
in this case I think that uh yeah he
could uh use another one to help him
score more points and Magnus he just
steals a Pawn on C3 we've seen magnets
with the Knight against the bishop a
couple times in this match already but
when you're up a few pawns you're just
happy to have any type of position
yeah definitely he is uh coordinating
that rook and Knight so well here and
there's no way you can stop that pawn
and you know what is stronger than the
world champion an Angry World Champion
what's he got there look at that he's
having to sit that does what is that
drink I'm intrigued Robert that looks a
bit juicy to me and Eric's got one as
well I want to be in that room yeah what
is that
I couldn't really tell it looks you know
orange so I couldn't tell if it was like
a mimosa but it wasn't a mimosa glass so
yeah I'm gonna have to
check out when they uh bring it up again
but we have another match going on of
course Magnus Carlson is always a
spectacle that people want to watch but
Min Lei you know he is taking on our
generic icy the winner of that match
will take on Magnus Carlson yes Eric has
some outside shot of winning this match
but if we're being realistic Magnus is
almost certainly going to sail through
so I am curious and will he indeed be
facing men because Min is the high rated
player in the other match and jumped out
to a lead
yes and uh yeah Ming is a dangerous
player I mean his speed his talent is
incredibly you know uh naturally
talented and he's got lots of experience
of the online format as well so uh it
looks in that match like we say that
that Ming is dominated dominating at the
moment uh I'm just intrigued we we know
what hopefully we're going to get into
and we that that is definitely on the
interview list of questions what are you
guys drinking I am jealous and uh we're
gonna see who it favors more of I guess
that drink Robert
yes well I think uh Magnus you know he's
gonna be happily sipping on that and
keeping himself refreshed but look at
the score in this match on the right
hand side five for men three for Arjun
I'm pretty sure it was five to one and
now Arjun with the black pieces wait
what just happened what was that we just
it blundered his Queen he Mouse slipped
ah no
he was that was a great chance to bring
the deficit to one point and uh he just
blundered his Queen bar as you say
Robert he is fighting back and I know
it's a three-point difference but
there's 13 minutes to go if you get some
roller wins you can still do this you
can still win this match
he was on a roll of wins that's the sad
part it is a win by two for those of you
who are just joining we keep reminding
you you need to win the matches by two
points and so for our generic geissi he
used that to cut that deficit to just
one game and to Mouse slip with 20 plus
seconds on your clock Simon that can be
backbreaking
yeah yes it's horrible and you've got to
try to get over that very very quickly
and Audrey must be seeing the camera
he's another player who comes across as
being very relaxed but maybe it's not so
I I think the challenge for Magnus and
Eric should be can they finish the drink
while playing a game of bullet and win
can can Magnus do that quite possibly
because you know we've got to make
things a little bit more difficult for
him I feel because he is just too too
strong
um well the position on the board is is
a pointer
sorry I saw a brilliant move from Min
late to win that game he sacked his
Queen for Rook to one another I saw the
two exclamation points and that's why I
stopped but now Min it seems like he is
trying to be a runaway train and for the
match that you you know you correctly
focused on Eric Hanson with the white
pieces here
he's winning
he is winning the black king is very
exposed the white Rooks are coming into
the position and white is a porn up can
he put the ball into the back of the net
though makes his King safe and just
playing a little move on the side he's
also got enough time here
um
and Magnus looking a little bit annoyed
the way he's playing at the moment
yeah it should be a win for one look at
them F5 he needs to get a second Rook to
E6 but watch out for the white king
suddenly their Queen D6 check and
where's that King going
oh gosh
oh dear
it's turning again oh oh that's a nice
tactic though getting the two Rooks or
the queen
and blank white horse has a draw here is
he gonna take the draw
he's got to try to win this one surely
and he is
yes and he is down on time that's the
problem for Eric so he has that draw
pretty much at any time he wants it
until the black queen goes to D2 like it
is now because you can't
look at Magnus crackers have another I
have another sip of your drink there
oh I think we were both thinking there's
no way you can lose this and then it was
Checkmate and he loses it commentators
curse there Robert
and it is karma in a way because
remember Magnus blunder that Checkmate
on G2 Queen takes G2 a few games ago uh
but for Eric you know he needed that
game desperately he seemed actually hurt
like his soul felt that pain and Magnus
is just having the time of his life
yeah yeah I think he enjoyed that one
right uh I mean do you prefer Robert
when you win a nice sort of gradual
positional game or a complete Swindle
what gives you the more satisfaction
oh I mean in bullet definitely A Swindle
because it just feels so good to be on
the cusp of defeat and then to sort of
laugh that off and just win a game and
your opponent you know is frustrated so
if you're playing a match that gives you
the upper hand but yeah I think that
both these players are not too upset
because they're drinking whatever that
delicious drink is
agree with that one
and the match score eight and a half to
one and a half for Magnus and in the
other match Arjun unfortunately is on a
bad roll here right it looked like he
was getting back into it but it's funny
how one little slip and he did I think
it was a mouse slip to blunder his Queen
you get dejected and look at that that
is just the blunder of a piece Arjun
just giving away a whole piece there and
it's looking very bad for him as well
now yeah and Min is so strong last year
he lost to dania and ended up in fourth
place but he was neck and neck it was a
tied match and been blundered and
allowed a Checkmate and that's how
Daniel was able to barely uh squeak by
him and make it to the top three so Min
he's been here before he wants to win
this and guess what you know what his
reward is Simon if he wins this match he
gets to play Magnus Carlson and you know
as a grand master who doesn't get
invitations to all the biggest events he
wants that opportunity even if it's in
bullet chess
yeah agreed I mean even though you're
probably likely to lose that match and
you realize that just the opportunity of
playing the best player in the world is
very very special and you never know you
know if things go your way and Ming is
capable of doing well against Magnus you
might cause a major upset it's it's
certainly more fun I think being the
underdog in these matches
going back to the games the score line
is pretty similar in both both matches I
mean uh Robert really I mean uh both
Magnus and Ming are dominating at the
moment oh Min just delivered a Checkmate
as soon as you're dominating it looked
like it was going to be a Trader Bishops
but he checkmates origin aragaisy and
unfortunately for origin it just isn't
his match once that Queen slipped
happened it was five to three at that
point now it's nine to three so uh Min
says I don't care how I get the job done
you asked do you prefer to get a Swindle
win Min says I don't care as long as I
keep winning
yeah a win is a win especially in bullet
yes and
um well again Eric in trouble in that
one and he loses and I want a bit of
shake of the head uh there's seven just
about seven eight minutes to go
we're seeing this opening a lot the
grunfeld
um
I remember the grunfeld as soon as you
lose as black that dark Square Bishop
which you can see black has done
protecting your king your king is always
a little bit weak and that could be an
issue for Eric here the black king
doesn't have much protecting it
Magnuson Magnus targeting the other side
of the board as well now and look at the
holes in the position the Black Knight
is about to go to C6 and then D4 the
White Knight would love to go to D5 at
some point so White's King feels very
safe because of this Pawn structure look
at this G2 F3 E4 G4 it's a weird
structure the dark squares may seem a
bit vulnerable but black as Wesley does
not the Firepower and he goes back when
he should have went forward I guess
yeah there was one chance there I think
for Eric and uh now again I prefer to be
white here that horn just coming
straight through uh the middle of the
board and another one joining it there
in the position
this is messy the black king looks
exposed but that pawn on D2 is super
strong and Magnus is like what did I
just do because he can't play F6 the
queen was loose in E5 he's gonna win the
D2 Pawn
yeah and he lost he lost his strongest
Pawn there and uh
Eric so laundering there I think because
now somehow I mean whatever whatever
Magnus does yeah even when he blunders
he seems to win I mean it's just
incredible yeah
I'm looking at Eric's clock and down to
10 seconds against Magnus 18 no chance
for Hanson he's a king F6 G5 check is
gonna happen always do this and the pawn
just runs off the board
yeah
yeah four seconds is not enough I'm not
trying to remember did Eric actually win
a game or was it just draws
the check
mate on G2 yes sorry yeah you're right
you mentioned that a second ago okay
what is that drink let's look what is
that
I reckon that is like some kind of
orange juice it peanut kind of pina
colada it can't be of orange juice
um but it looks so nice yeah
whatever it was I want one do you reckon
they've hired in a special cocktail
waiter just for the match I mean that
would be quality you know let's get a
cocktail maker just for our match
that would be excellent maybe you know
one of their friends that they're on
this trip with just happens to be an
expert mixologist I mean I'm whatever is
happening there I want in on it because
first of all Barcelona sounds lovely no
matter the time of year uh whatever
they're having I would like some oh gosh
Eric does not want to have any part of
that skewer on the diagonal he's oh E5
back rank Rook D1 take B1
yeah oh dear it's all gone a bit wrong
and uh
there goes
oh he doesn't even want the bishop
straight away he's doing it much
cleverly attacking The Rook
and another piece is dropping there you
can see that Eric's
a bit upset with the way things are
going
and we're hearing a bit more information
and apparently the the cocktail Mark the
maker is Eric's brother Dylan so who is
very good at making cocktails so we're
hearing that first hand
and again make sure you check out the
chess bras they are on or around Europe
at the moment too you spot them you
might even better
get a game against them
I'm just curious if it's an actual
brother or because their bras are they
like Bros in that way like I feel like
it's probably not his actual biological
brother not to say that those kind of oh
it is we're being told it is
sorry Dylan my apologies
I just assumed you know they're bras so
and they got that going but
wow they got a lot they've got a little
bra for friends haven't they there's a
lot of brawls out there chest bras
yeah they really are they're on a tour
right now so I mean you could follow
their schedule I don't know it off the
top of my head but they are they were in
London I believe now in Spain so they're
meeting with many chess fans
yeah good thing to do and one of the
great things about modern chess you can
stream your activities as you go around
and again looking at the positions you
can see that this is Magnus attacking I
love it when we see matters attacking so
we don't always get it as a Checkmate
must be coming out Black's King has too
many pieces hovering around it the magic
number when attacking is normally three
pieces and white has those three pieces
the queen is ready to dive in one square
fours will be checked mate you can't
defend that with a bishop because white
can just take the bishop due to the pin
and uh I can't see any way to defend
that there Robert Magnus winning another
game
yeah did you see that feature chat death
taxes and Magnus winning at chess that
that seems fair Magnus just does it all
the time and 13 and a half to one half
so Eric knew that this was going to be a
tough one he knew he was going to lose
the match but do you think he believed
to get more than one half points against
Magnus
I I reckon he you've got to believe that
haven't you otherwise why are you there
you've got to believe that you're gonna
score okay you know there's no point
going into the match thinking I'm going
to lose every game I mean Eric's not
that kind of guy you know Eric's a great
player and on his day when things go
right he can he can score more points
um now the position here I mean I'd love
to see another win from Eric this is a
good chance right he seems to be doing
okay Magnus sacrificed The Exchange but
it looks a bit dubious to me Robert
uh yeah because two exchanges I was
trying to quickly count what's the
material it is two minor pieces for two
Rooks but his Knight is coming to D5 and
maybe into E3 and C3 those kind of
annoying squares and look at the
evaluation how does Magnus do this right
it still looks problematic for black oh
D hangers oh he just drops his roof
oh no
oh
wow okay that I mean how does Magnus do
it Robert you you were saying I don't
know how does he do it I just watched it
happen and I still can't answer the
question and uh yeah Magnus normally he
laughs when something like that happens
I think he's starting to feel a little
bit bad
well there's only a minute 24 left and
they can get to the serious activity of
more cocktails and enjoying the
nightlife in Barcelona which I'm sure
they're both looking forward to doing
very shortly but a very powerful
performance from Magnuson just to remind
everyone is double elimination so Eric
will have another chance which is great
and Magnus will be progressing to the
next round and he's gonna be playing uh
the winner and the winner seems to be
decided in the other match
to minlay is so strong if he weren't
alongside the match of Magnus Carlsen we
would have definitely been focusing on
his games against Arjun Eric icy Arjun
Air Guys he's a super Grandmaster one of
the biggest prodigies on the planet
signed a huge sponsorship deal uh that
was worth I believe over one million
dollars I think it was 1.5 if I'm
remembering correctly and we know that
he is a superstar not just in the making
he's currently a superstar but look at
Mingo Bishop A2 check he wants to
deliver a Checkmate against that King
and he's looking for it he wants to find
it and will he is the question it looks
like the answer might be no
yep
um not long to go now
just have to reboot sign quickly oh good
Min just wanted to reboot his brain
because he walked into a checkmates and
he laughed about it uh but looks like
Magnus up
25 seconds against Eric in their final
game probably going to win that one as
well and Min he wants to win every game
he plays but he's down to pawn against
Arjun in their final game
so we're looking uh at these two matches
it's been decided Magnus Carlson huge
winner over Eric Hansen and minlay
winning by six points right now but he
might lose this final game as well to
make it a five-point margin he did just
drop a piece there so Min versus Magnus
will be the case but Arjun yeah Arjun
will probably make his presence felt in
the losers bracket so Simon I mean
Magnus doing Magnus things it looks like
Arjun lost his uh connection there
unfortunately we would love to get him
back but clever Noir MK Min is having a
wonderful time yes indeed so Simon last
game here between Magnus and Eric
yeah it's um you know great play from
Magnus and you know great play all round
I mean like it's great to see them also
just enjoying that drink and do you
think we're gonna be able to get into
you with one of them
oh I maybe both at the same time while
they're making new drinks I feel like
that's commonplace for the chess bra
scene but right now I think that Eric
wants to forget about this match and I
know a way he can forget about it thanks
Simon we could think of a few ways so he
is memory will be short term
oh